stephen max in his first start since
june 12th he had a positive covet test
max is going to be on some sort of pitch
count tonight there's only
so much strength he's going to have
here's ty france for a guy like steven
matz it had kind of run its course with
the new york mets
that kind of maybe labeled him and he
gets a chance to go to spring training
and kind of strut his stuff again
france with the ground ball the check
off the back leg gets the out quick one
two three inning
steven max so on the hill there's
justice sheffield
25 years old left-hander came over in
the james paxton trade with the yankees
here's vladimir guerrero jr 4 46 on base
685 slugging i just think the game
humbled them what
what do you want to be right all the
tools in the world and there we talk
about his chase rate not
not coming outside the zone he gets a
slider down there and he goes after him
here's teowska hernandez
the one-two took something off that as
well gloved
and short by crawford oh they got him
wow came off first base double play
inning over kyle siegert seeger torrens
and
bowers seeger strikes out bases loaded
for goriel
he's not having a big year 86 weighted
runs created plus below league average
again 100 is league average if you don't
speak this language
283 on base 413 slugging hasn't hit as
of yet
payoff pitch
[Applause]
lifted into right field that should be
deep enough henniger can throw but
not like that springer tags up he's
going to score
bridgette goes into third as well one
nothing blue jay's on top
marcus simeon top of the order simeon
and beshet and guerrero
big spot here three and two first and
third two outs
sheffield was close again marcus simeon
beschette on deck
seeger off the ground ball and trammell
came over in the uh trevor bauer trade
glavin could dot it
a nat's rear end any time he wanted to
on that outer half
and he would just force you to commit to
it steven matz that's always been his mo
the fastball whoa nice wow you're
bouncing that off the wall
hitting rockets coming to the plate
pichet
on the ground no and it's all tied up
you know we don't have a play to the
plate oh hey bunt
there it is we've seen everything oh
look at this jp
scores we're seeing singles bunts
brings up mitch hanniger when mr jerry
depotto hung that phone up
with brody van wagone and and he
unloaded robertson
that was game-changing yeah and got
kelnick now kelnick is down in the
miners but he'll be back
big strikeout there for mats mitch
hanniger strikes out ty
france stepping up tight friends by the
way is miked up
for us coach carson way better today
good penmanship yesterday was horrible
yesterday that's a doubt the color combo
too
like it makes the red pop lots of
fastballs down the middle today okay
look the giants i don't think they'd be
the best team in baseball best team in
the national league
struck him out gets france and that's a
big out two outs now with a man on
brings up kyle seeger who's in the last
year of his deal i think they have an
option on him next year but
unlikely to pick that up he's been an
outstanding player for this
organization though 3-1
hit hard left field again that ball is
traveling to left field and
that's gone big two-run shot kyle seeger
there must be a a wind tunnel going out
there to left field
going out to the left that is the second
shot that we've seen hit out there that
gets out in a hurry to left field
two run shot for kyle seeger two on
nobody out
they oscar hernandez steps in mentioned
hernandez finalists for the all-star
vote
two and two to te oscar hernandez
okay oh he's [ __ ] got that as a ball
yeah it's a great pitch it was but if
that box is not there you're saying
it's a strike randall grichik steps up
first and third
now looks more of a thing hit hard down
the line basic
bo buchet will score
and they get another run gotta play at
the plate diving
vlad is in wow and although and grichik
goes all the way to third vladimir
guerrero jr beautiful base running
brings up kevin biggio two and two to
kevin bizio
steps up man on third the game is being
swallowed whole by the three true
outcomes
and it's our fault it's the saber
metrics fault i was going
to say swallow no one to blame but
yourself it's a three it's like the nba
it's a three-point shoot-a-thon because
it makes sense
no we'll get it you win this next half
marcus simeon steps up
balls hit hard left field and off the
wall
didn't go out
that'll drive in a run
their offense doesn't stop ah they pull
down 4-1
keep us there riley adams scores marcus
simeon drives it another run
and here's vlad guerrero jr oh wow
justice sheffield battles back and this
is mitch henniger
here's the pitch the hennig is swinging
a high fly ball deep in the left field
hernandez going back looking up into the
night and goodbye baseball it's way out
here to left field
hanager launches another home run
419 feet tom murphy steps in he's over
two
oh did he strike out the side yes he did
anthony k after some early damage
the runners are now at first and third
with chew outs and louis gurion jr is
the batter
and a base hit driving in a run we got a
6'5 game
finding a hole on the right side good
hitting by gorielle
faces are loaded and goes to the top of
the order and marcus simeon
smoked him 96 up top
here's hernandez scott surface told us
earlier today
he said look we have one of the younger
clubs in the league and we can punch up
because we have bullpen not big names
but guys that
a lot of people haven't heard of that
are getting it done seawall was one of
the guys he mentioned and gloved
at short crawford made that play
lourdes gorilla riley adams and marcus
simeone
and that ball is launched wow
high ball game indeed into the buffalo
night
419 feet same distance of the handicraft
sorry you had that by the time it landed
[Applause]
shout out to stackhouse that all i did
was look at a page that's your
eight-hole hitter right there
hernandez is all for four
smacked nice play
ty france well done at first base and it
brings up
dylan moore that balls hit hard
oh wow that ball is gone
a bomb from dylan moore and a three-run
blast for seattle
these guys are and 8-1 in extra innings
and looking good for nine and one
biggio is one for three he was at the
plate
when randall griczyk was caught stealing
on review
out there hit hard by vizio to right
field
over the head of hanukkah and that's
going to drive in a run
and quickly the blue jays are within two
well that was quick
marcus steps up with two outs to man on
the one two again top of the zone and he
popped him up
and the mariners get the win and they
take game two
in this series